Khaled, I see you opened your m your
your cam. You ready? Thumbs up if you're
ready. All right, Khaled, joining the
stage. What's up, man? What's up? You
born a Muslim? Raised in raised into
Islam. Raised into Islam. Yes. Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Cool. What What have you
heard about uh about the Quran and its
preservation? Growing up in Islam, being
born a Muslim, being raised in Islam.
What have you heard about the
preservation of the Quran? It has it had
some it had stages. It was prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam received it
told to the companions. They wrote it
down. They read it to him again. Then
there was
uh uh some people uh who were there were
wars and people who memorized the
Qurans. The thing is with Abu Bakr you
know
and I'm well informed I think. Okay. So
you know how the Quran was I guess
compiled in a way but uh so what about
its preservation was it preserved letter
for letter um are there any variances or
differences what have you been of course
there's uh there's seven variants the
Quran
um uh and people have tried to gather to
gather it they had three
um premises to accept
Mhm. Which was uh the
the when you write something what what
is it called the skeleton of uh of the
written it has to be the same thing and
it has to be grammat grammatically
correct and it has to
be which means it is uh it's from it's
from Allah. It is mass uh transmitted.
Yeah, mass transmitted like this. Those
are three. Uh so it has to have the same
script. It has the same script. Does
someone have a script? Yeah, the
skeleton you said it has to say the same
the same script, right? Yes. And man
wrote six uh six copies. Six copies and
sent them. And those six those are the
uh those are ones and the rest was
burnt. Are they all the same? There are
little differences. There are little
differences like like what do you mind?
Uh do you mean the skeleton? It's
nothing nothing big. It's for example in
there's a difference cuz
the from Medina. Uhhuh.
And had a it's additional. Okay. So they
don't they don't all have they don't all
have the same script because you were
saying they all have the same skeleton
before. I said we have six copies and
they were sent out and we have uh to
build on those six copies. It has to
match but but they don't have the same
script. They don't have the same script.
Yes. The same script means the script of
it has to match the script
of all six of those don't have the same
all six of those are they're not
identical with each other. The prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
um there's a hadith from Do you
understand Arabic? Yeah. Yeah, we
understand. It
says
no. You need some help.
this is the first
thing. So the prophet said we have to
follow the sunnah which is his teachings
and the four califfs that will come and
uh that's why it's no problem if there
are small mistakes. Oh, mistakes.
They're mistakes. My vocabulary is not
very I think you know what mistake is.
Doesn't need Yeah, I know what mistakes
is, but I have to be fluent when I talk.
Um when it's when there are variations,
it's no not a problem. It's not a
mistake. I will take this back. Okay.
With a slip of tongue. Um but we have to
follow the four and is one of and he has
written those six copies. So anything uh
he wrote in his copies is uh taken from
us and accepted from us because the
prophets told us that he
was bite onto it very hard. So it's not
a problem. Okay. I I don't want to I
mean you're taking a lot of time to say
this. Basically what I'm asking you is
are the scripts identical with
themselves or not? Yes or no? No. Okay.
So So they're
not they're not identical. So they're
not identical. They're not identical.
Okay. So the question is did Muhammad
approve all of them? Yes. Okay. How did
he approve all of them? I was not there
obviously. But we have the chains of
narrations.
Everyone uh he has a teacher. He read
the Quran unto him and this teacher read
the Quran unto his teacher and it goes
all all the way back to the prophet
Muhammad. Okay. So you're saying that
there's no mistake. You don't believe
there's any mistakes. Is that what the
early scholars said? what you're saying
or is this what later scholars said what
exactly about mistakes in mistakes so
basically if there's mistakes in these
various readings of the Quran all the if
there's mistakes in those then they
can't possibly go back to Muhammad right
yes the pro Muhammad wasallam he read
the Quran in seven tongues and wait so
you think that the seven are the theat
or is that what you think of course not
exactly because we have more than the
tongues Okay. But but I'm asking you
specifically about if there's mistakes
because I'm asking if they go back to
Muhammad or not. So I'm asking did the
early scholars believe that there were
mistakes in the different Qurans that
they had the different readings of the
Quran or did they say that these are all
go back to Muhammad? There are um that
they are called for example the of from
it is not considered that's why we have
to put
premises out of the 10 the one that you
said I I'm only talking about those ones
only the only the only the ones that are
mass transmitted the one that you accept
only those ones are there any mistakes
in those there are variations yes but
mistakes
not new info You are obviously alluding
to something. Yeah. Yeah. I don't I'm
not asking you if there's differences.
I'm saying is there a mistake? A
mistake? Like is there an error? I I
don't know. You tell me. Okay. So,
you're cuz you're saying something and
when I read the early scholars of Islam,
they tell me something different because
you're saying they all I asked you the
question, do they all go back to
Muhammad? You said yes, they all go back
to Muhammad because they all have a
chain. But if I look at the early
scholars, they don't tell me that all of
these go back to Muhammad. They say some
of these are, you know, maybe more
correct than other ones. For example, if
I say to you, this reading is more
correct than that reading. Does that
make sense if they're both from Allah,
both from Muhammad? Look, we have
10, right? But we have seven, the
prophet told us seven. So there is
uh uh in the collection or the gathering
or the compilation of the of theat. This
is not easy. It is much more than 10
Quran actually. Yeah, I know that. But
I'm only talking about I'm only talking
about the mass transmitted on the ones
you were talking about. I'm asking you
if there's any mistakes in those because
I and I give you an example. If I tell
you that this reading is more correct
than that reading, does that make sense
if I believe that they both are from
Allah and they're both from Muhammad?
What does more correct mean? I I don't
understand. Is there a uh
the one It's more This is more correct
than this.
What what is and what what does this
what does that's what I'm asking I'm
asking you I'm ask that's what I'm
asking you is it possible to say that if
I believe these are both from God can
something from God be more correct than
something from God or does it make sense
what is more what can be more correct is
the transmission not the transmission
I'm talking about the words themselves
the words themselves but we're not
talking about transmission right now we
already established we're only talking
about the ones that are the ones that
have mass transmission. So forget about
transmission. We're talking about the
words themselves.
God's word is God's word if one word and
the other word both are and there's
nothing which is okay. Okay. Perfect. So
that I'm I'm glad that you said that.
Now so let's go to a very classic
example you
know verse four where
Yes. Exactly. So, we're going to go to
for example, and we're going to see what
did he say. Did he believe that some
readings can be more correct? Or did he
say that? No, no, no, no. Muhammad said
it like this. Muhammad said it like
that. Muhammad said it like this.
Muhammad said it like that. What? What?
What did he What did he say? Let's put
us on the screen, please.
Okay. So, we're going to go to Before we
um Before we list, uh you sound like you
know Islam well, but do you know who Abu
Jafar is? Abu Jafar
the or the
the Abu Jafar. Yes. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Well, okay. Fine. Well, we told you. But
okay. No problem. So, anyway, uh read
what he's saying here and we'll we'll uh
we'll translate or if you want to
translate, whatever. No problem. Just
we'll just we'll just do this sentence
and then uh you know, you you I'll
translate it. I'll translate. Yeah. Then
God logic will translate it.
Okay. Milk.
Okay, let's deal with this part first.
So, what did you understand uh from this
just so for people who don't understand
Arabic or if you want us to translate
it, we we can translate. No problem. But
your choice, your choice. And he says
the the thing I consider uh more or
better uh the better interpretation or
the better meaning is because it's more
no it's not
meaning please translate correctly. He
says what does mean the more correct of
those two Mhm. two what of those two uh
tongues or two tongues? Come on. Don't
Don't do this to us now. Don't do this
to us now. I I I don't mean to. It's
really It's just Give me the word. Uh
give me the word in English.
See, Abraham. Yeah, there you go. So,
the the more correct of the two
readings. It's okay. Your Arabic is
good. My English is good. We help each
other. Okay. uh the more correct uh
reading of those two readings in the
recitation in in my opinion or in my for
me is the first uh interpretation or the
first how can I say let's watch you're
right first interpretation that's right
okay now keep going and what what is
this first interpretation the first the
better of the two readings what is it to
say Melik the king the king perfect okay
perfect so let's just deal with this
part first because we'll go on to his
reason afterwards, but just so
everybody's clear uh what we're talking
about here. Okay, so um what's it what's
our friend's
name? Okay, so um our friend um Khaled
here was uh saying that you have these
readings that are from Muhammad, from
Allah that are all inspired. They're all
God's words and there's no mistakes, no
errors in them. So I asked them I said
okay if we go to the early scholars do
the early scholars have that belief that
these are all the word of God that these
are all inspired that these are all the
same sets the same level or if we go to
these scholars can some of them for
example say well this reading is better
than that reading it's more correct than
that reading as does it make sense to
say that one reading is better than
another reading if they're both the word
of God so for a Christian example I
could be like all Is John 1:1 more
correct than you know Mark 1:1? A
Christian? No, you can't say it's more
correct. It's these are the word of God.
It's equal. They're both inspired word
of God. So we
have the same way. True. We have here a
scholar a big big big scholar who a big
a big commentator and he didn't he's not
just a commentator as he also was a
scholar of the different readings. He
actually wrote a book on this but it's
it lost us through history like we don't
have it in and yeah but he actually
wrote a book on this topic and he says
actually these two very popular readings
that Muslims accept and read today for
example if you're in Morocco you're
going to be reading the Quran this way
if you're in uh basically almost any
country outside of these few countries
in North
Africa. So he's saying that there's a
more correct reading. And so the
question is how can he say that there's
more correct if they're both from God,
if they're both inspired. And he goes on
to give an argument for why he says one
of them is better than the others. So
what so just so just so everyone's on
the same page, everyone understands cuz
we don't want to get lost in
translation. Okay. So back to you. What
what's your response? In terms of truth,
the uh if someone says something and
says something else, he said both. But
what is what has no value or the value
can be different. For example, we have
it is best ayah in the Quran. We have
fat is the best surah in the Quran for
example. But it doesn't does not mean
that this is more correct. He said is
fat more correct than Bakar. What does
correct mean? Any correct? Exactly.
Exactly. So what does correct mean? Now
we're now we're talking what does
correct mean? What? First we say what's
now we're saying what does correct mean?
Wow. So we're okay. All of a sudden we
don't know what correct means. Yeah. We
don't know what mistake means. No
problem. Okay. No problem. But now
correct. We don't know what correct
means. That's the miracle of the Quran,
my friend. Now all of a sudden the words
don't mean what they mean. So what does
correct mean? What do you think correct
mean? You mean true. It is both from
Allah.
So how can one how can one be more true
than the other? What what I understood
from he said this one Malik to say king
is better than say Malik which means the
one who possess possesses because a
human being can possess something but if
you say Malik there's only one Malik and
there's it's it's more powerful to say
not powerful more correct correct yeah
more more true like you said so this is
my interpretation this is my
interpretation so which one is better
again sorry which one is better is it
Malik or Malik better. Yeah. What?
Whatever you said more correct, more
true, whatever. Which one is different?
It's different. No, you didn't say
different. You just explained it to us.
You said if you say What I mean was
different is if you say uh Malik and
Malik, both are true. It's the same.
You're saying both are true, but that's
not what No, that's not what in the
interpretation better because No,
listen. Hold on. You're you're saying
this you're saying that these are both
from Allah. So you're saying that these
are both true. These are both on the
same level. That's what you're saying.
Did the early scholars say that or only
the later scholars when they were trying
to propagate certain lies about Islam?
What happened? Because the early
scholars and this is only just one
reference. We can show you where Ibujah
himself the one who canonized the or who
the one who compiled and got you the
seven readings the first seven readings.
He himself believed that there were
errors errors and mistakes in these
different and he's the one who compiled
them. He uses words like like these are
these are wrong. These are errors. So
can we just stick with so which one did
he prefer? Let's go prefer just to not
make you you know shake. I understood he
preferred Malik. Okay. What do you what
do you Muslims say today? Uh we say
Malik and we say Malik. Okay. With the
majority of Muslims, what do they say?
They read on and they say Malik. Okay.
So, you're reading the less So, you're
reading the less correct, less preferred
one. Do you agree? Most of you, most of
you. According to According to If you
want to put it No, I don't want to. I'm
not the one who said it. I'm not I'm
just I'm just trying to get to the
conclusion. The thing is the Quran has
many ayat. Just answer the question. Do
most of you recite the in terms of this?
Yes. And yeah, you're right. in terms of
this ay but there's a lot of other ayat
and it's uh there's maybe yes but you're
right very much so most today recite the
less preferred less correct one so the
point is is that we're going back to
what you're saying these all go back to
Muhammad why on earth would this scholar
who comes way before you he knows Arabic
better than you he knows Islam better
than you why would he ever say that This
is a better reading than that if he if
he believed that these are both from
Muhammad. Like if you ask God logic, if
you ask myself, if you ask daughter of
Christ uh about the sayings of Jesus and
and people ask, "Hey, which one is more
correct?" We would say, "What are you
talking about more correct? What do you
mean? These are all from like these are
from the gospels. These are all correct.
They're all the same level. They're
inspired. They're from the mouth of the
Lord Jesus Christ himself." So we would
tell you there's no such thing as more
correct or less correct. But why do your
early scholars, and like I said, I can
give you many examples, not just this is
just one because we're we have to go one
at a time. We can't do everything at
once. Why do they say that there's less
correct and more correct? If they all
come from Muhammad, they all come from
Allah. Again what I what he says is this
what he means by it it it is the better
meaning because a king is more unique to
someone who only possesses because I can
be a possessor of someone and someone
else the better the better reading he
says the better reading. So how can a
human being say better reading for me?
He says, "Okay, so how can your scholar
say that opinion?" Obviously, so how can
your scholar have an opinion of a better
reading of your god's speech? How can he
that's what we're getting at? How can he
judge what's better and what's worse?
He's a human understand why it's
complicated because he is more unique to
someone who possesses. It's not it's not
complicated. So he just he just I don't
think you understand. I don't think you
understand the problem here. So you
don't have an issue with your scholars
saying that some of Allah's words are
more correct than other parts of his
words. No problem. It's he didn't say
this like this. He didn't put it like
this. You just said he did. You were the
one who translated it. Yeah. He Yeah. So
you're the one. So that's why I get
offered if you wanted to translate it.
No problem. But uh I think you get the
point. Uh we're going in circles at this
point. But we have many many many more
examples where they actually use harsh
language like saying this is our
mistake. Yeah. This is an error. You
know what means or does it suddenly mean
something else? Or does true means
something else? Yeah, they all they all
knew what it means. Means means mistake
and we have to take it seriously. If
someone says it. Okay. What if what if
Aisha said it? What would you say? If
Aisha said it, I would take it
seriously. Even if a scholar said, I I
have to. But what I saw now from he
said which is my what I prefer is a
better word because it delivers the
meaning more uh it's better. It's more
correct. Thank you. Well, thank you K
for coming man. I appreciate you
participating man. Oh, he's gone. Oh,
wait. Hold on one second. Let's just
show you guys show one more thing. Okay.
Yeah, just one more thing before uh
before our friend here uh goes. Maybe
you know about this one, maybe not. But
uh the Arabic is a little small. Uh so
we can make it we'll we'll read. Yeah,
there we can do that, too. I guess we
can do that. Do you see that? Okay,
let's zoom out a little bit so you can
see it
better. Okay,
do you do you see it? Yeah, there's also
what is it? Okay. So they
asked about this. Do you do you agree
this is in your Quran today?
Yeah. Okay. And also about another
verse. And another verse. Yeah. And in
another
verse. Yeah.
Also,
sorry. What does mean? They uh have made
a mistake in writing. Okay. So, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on. Let me write
it. Actually, they made a mistake in the
book. Let's finish it. Hold on. Writing
doesn't continue. Wait, wait. Can you
continue to read because we're talking
about chains and can you continue? Mhm.
What does it say? Okay. Thank you. So,
now that you got it in English, we'll
put it in Arabic. Sorry. Now that you
got it in Arabic, we'll put it in
English for everyone else. Okay. Uh, so
go ahead. So this is
from this is about when they asked about
the word means grammatical error as
grammatical errors in a few verses
in uh surah 20:63 surah 4:162 and surah
5:69 she said this is the work of the
scribes they made mistakes in the book
you say in the writing okay no problem
because writing is in a book and this is
so there's your word these verses are
Exactly. In your Quran today, those same
mistakes have survived to your Quran
today according to Aisha. Okay. Um let
me read it again because I
zoom in. You can take a screenshot if
you like. Come back to Yeah, I I I will.
This is uh let's zoom in. So just to be
clear guys, Aisha is saying that there
are errors in the Quran. Yes. In the
Quran that most Muslims would be using
even today. actually
almost I I I don't know of any
variations actually. Yeah. Yeah. Some of
these verses have no variation across
all the readings. So yeah, these are
mistakes that exist in all Quran. All
the Muslims will be reading these mis
what Aisha is saying are mistakes. Yeah.
All of them. Yeah. Definitely all the
all the Quran. Perfectly preserved
mistakes. Yes. Exactly. Perfectly
preserved mistakes. Now remember what
Khaled said. He said if Aisha said
there's a mistake, I'll accept it.
Seriously, I can't I have no knowledge
of this. I cannot give you uh an answer.
See, that's a great way to approach it.
We had someone else earlier, not to
compare you or anything. Well, I guess I
am comparing you, but you're better.
Yeah, we we had someone earlier who they
like to give like a like a sermon and a
fatwa and everything and but you have a
humble approach. You look if you don't
know about it, good. You want to
screenshot it, you can fact check it,
you can look. Yeah, I have I have
screenshot. I I will ask my uh teacher
Quran by Yeah, I know. It's a well-known
book. It's one of the books in Quran.
Okay. So, then how come it's the first
time you've read it? If it's one of the
books, not I haven't I haven't read it.
Honestly, I haven't read it. It's a It's
a famous book, right? You know, you know
the book. It is a book. I know the
books. I know the books of the sciences.
Okay. Great. So, they say that said that
and those are there in your book today.
Yeah. I I will uh I will look it up and
I I uh will consider
uh inshallah. Okay, this is a this is
provoking thoughts. Oh, good. It's nice
nice to meet you. Nice to speak to you
as well. Good to meet you. Where are you
from? We don't we don't we don't give a
because you know the followers of your
religion of peace wants us to be pieces.
Yeah. Because we are. But you're you're
a nice guy though. You're nice. Yeah.
Not you though. But you are Christian
also or Yeah, we're Christian. Yes,
we're Christian. And uh what would you
okay you told me you gave me critique in
in Islam. Um what is uh this is if you
are saying Christianity is better what
is the uh the alternative that I can
look forward to. Yeah it's a beautiful
question. If I decided to go to
Christianity for example, what is do I
do I not have these mistakes or these uh
differences or like this uh this type of
things? It's a great great question.
Okay. So you you know how you mentioned
like you have like
uh like shawad uh the readings that are
not accepted but that you you don't call
them canonical like you wouldn't accept
these readings, right? Mhm. Okay. So in
Christianity uh we don't have like uh
like let's say the gospel of John we
don't have like seven different versions
of the gospel of John that we say these
are all the same like these are all
inspired by God all seven different
versions and they have you know
different dialects and different accents
so there's one gospel of John right like
gospel according to John gospel
according to Mark according to Luke
according to Matthew one for each okay
so we don't have this problem where we
say like there's multiple inspired
versions of Matthew like there's five
versions of Matthew or seven versions of
Mark there's one version okay and yes
there are manuscripts like you have
manuscripts of the Quran and sometimes a
scribe might make an error here or there
but the original is preserved in the in
the manuscript tradition so we don't
have this problem where we say like okay
this how these are all you have you have
you have manuscripts Yeah. And they do
mistakes, but they are without mistakes.
This is what I understand. Exactly. We
don't say that these these the scribes,
we're not saying that these scribes are
like it's a like and these are all like
No, we say look these are scribes and
some of them preserve their words and
sometimes some of them will make
mistakes, right? Like we can give you
examples of that in the Quran as well.
When they're writing the Quran,
sometimes they make a mistake. It's no
problem. But the the differences in
Islam is that you guys believe well you
believe that these are all inspired and
these are all the differences that we
just showed you that these are all
inspired and these are all equal of
equal status to God. So if you showed me
two manuscripts of the Gospel of Mark
for example like Mark chapter 1 and you
show me one manuscript that said one
thing and one that said another thing I
wouldn't have that problem that you
have. I wouldn't have to say oh this one
they're both from God but this one's
more true than the other one. This one's
less true than the other. I wouldn't
have to do that because There's only one
there's only one version just one
version that was inspired and we believe
that it's preserved in our tradition of
manuscripts. So there might be questions
that people have like is this the
original reading or that is that the
original reading but nobody is saying
that you know both ways are like it's
like let's say we have two options. No
one's saying both of these are correct.
We're saying one of them is the inspired
word of God and one of them was acribed
mistake, right? Like does that make
sense? Yeah, I I understand the point.
Okay. But uh it's kind of it's kind of
similar how you how you see like the
Shaz uh readings like they're you don't
you don't accept them and they differ
and they're not you don't consider them
to be inspired or you don't consider
from God. That's kind of similar to how
we would view manuscripts that deviate
from the original manuscript that
deviate from I think is more similar to
your apocryraphical books. Maybe. Yeah,
maybe you could you could say that too.
But I'm just trying to give you an
example of we don't have like and you
know we don't say like that you know we
say there's only one one version. So we
don't have this problem where you know a
a scholar comes and says both of these
are from God but this one's more correct
than this one. No, we we say one of them
is the inspired word of God and we have
to do some scholarship and some work and
you know by God's grace with help of the
Holy Spirit to figure out which one did
you know John originally say for example
or write right yeah and and and they all
um uh the message of the gospel is
basically gospel or injil is the meaning
it's it's actually um not an Arabic word
the injil it's a Greek word it means
good news good news so what is the good
news. The good news is the Lord Jesus
Christ came to save us from hell. All of
us deserve hell because all of us have
broken God's law. You made mistake. We
all did. God's law is perfect and we all
the Quran also. We're not talking about
the Quran now. We're talking about
gospel. Yeah. So you asked what is it
that the Christianity will offer you?
Well, Christianity will offer you rescue
from hell. Anyone who does not accept
the gift of the Lord Jesus to be saved,
rescued. Basically, the message is you
can't do it yourself. You can't do good
works on one side of the scale and on
this side and say on this side. It
doesn't work like that. What you need
because that means that you can climb
your way to God. You can do do it
yourself. God says you can't do it.
You've already broken my law. You've
already is a criminal in my eyes. But
that means we all deserve hell. So what
so what does that So there's a problem.
But God solves the problem by putting
that punishment that we deserve. The
punishment has to go on someone. So he
puts it on the Lord Jesus Christ. And
when that happens, we are now clean
before God. Like if you get a a fine,
let's say you you parked wrong, you got
a fine, someone pays the fine for you so
that you don't have to go to prison.
That's what the Lord Jesus did for us.
That's the message. Okay? If you decide
to pay the fine yourself, you go to
hell. Everybody has that choice. So
that's the choice for you. That's what
what happens when you come to the Lord
Jesus. You become in front of God
righteous. You become like him. When he
sees you, he sees the the the fine is
being paid. And then you have and then
not only that, but you also get uh the
right to be called a child of God. What
does a child of God mean? It means he
adopted you into his family. So you no
long before you were his enemy.
Remember, you were the criminal. So not
only did he pay the fine for you, he
adopted you into his family. So you can
call yourself child of God. And then he
gives you his spirit, okay, to come
inside you. And that spirit of God is
basically God living inside you. The
only Christianity can is a religion
where God comes to live inside you. What
does that mean? It means that every time
your nature, your human nature that
still wants to do wrong, every time you
want to do that, the spirit of God stops
you. The spirit of God cleanses you. The
spirit of God makes you better until we
become perfect when the Lord Jesus
comes. I wish. So, so we encourage you,
we encourage you to read read the
gospel, okay? So, read the uh you can
start with Matthew Mata,
okay? And you can read this Gospel of
Matthew. Start with this and by the time
you get to chapter 5, you become a
Christian. That's what happens. So, be
careful and be safe. But before you do
all of that, you ask God himself, the
one who created you, okay? Whether Islam
is wrong or whatever, say, "Please guide
me." You have to have humility. Yeah.
Yeah. Please guide me to yourself. That
means if God shows you Islam is wrong,
you have to leave it. No pride, no my
family, this, my upbringing, this, my
this, my that. God doesn't care about
these things. So you ask God first like
that and then you open the gospel. We we
we say ma and then Matthew or any gospel
actually you can try as well John Gospel
of John any gospel. And then what
happens is God himself comes and helps
you. We believe that no one can convert
only the spirit of God can change you
like not us speaking or anything that's
why you need to pray and you need to
read. Yes. So yeah thank you. Thank you
so much for coming and uh we really
appreciate the conversation with you.
This is it. Okay. God bless you.
May the real God guide us all to the
real truth. And uh we have we pray that
for you. We do. We thank you. Thank you.
We pray for you. Okay. This is not
sincere. Not sincere. All that after all
that was not sincere. Oh, well he he he
just pulled like Oh, I'm just kidding,
guys. And like I don't know what that
means, but anyway, I think he means
we're not sincere. Okay. Well, well, we
we obviously we're Christians. We we
know that we have the truth. We know the
Lord Jesus Christ. He said, "I am the
truth." So, we don't need to pray that
God guides us to the truth. Like, we
don't know the truth already. We know
the truth. And that's not arrogance or
anything. It's because the Lord Jesus
makes himself known to us. And you can
know him, too. You can know the truth.
The the Apostle Paul said, "I know whom
I believed. I know. And you can know him
too. You can know. The Lord Jesus says
that the son will set you free. You know
the son, he'll set you free. You know
the truth. Sorry. You know the truth and
truth will set you free. Yeah. Sorry.
That's right. That's right. Excellent
work, my beautiful brother and sister,
giant DLC. Man, love hearing you guys
give the gospel, breaking down Islam,
and then building them up with the
gospel. And that's what you guys see
what we do when someone um you know we
we're we're here to tear down the walls
of Islam to tear down the walls of lies
and to unplug the ears but we don't
leave them there right we don't leave
them there when if they have a if they
have a genuine you know question or
intrigue about well then what is the
truth what's what's the alternative we
got you now you're open to hear now we
can give you this without it being
without the waters being muddied with
Islam. So, uh that's the strategy and it
works with the power of God, man. It
works. It works. It works. Good to see
you.